gas today is 52
more expensive than it was at this same
time last year the price of eggs is up
at least 23
the cost of milk is up 38
in just one year
and i would bet that your income has not
gone up 23 or 38 or 52
actually there's a good chance you lost
your job after politicians shut your
country down for two years of two weeks
to slow the spread of a virus that
almost certainly does not pose any
serious threat to you
the inflation rate overall is 7.9
the highest it's been in 40 years and if
you're concerned about how you're going
to make ends meet well you're just a big
stupid ingrate according to joe biden
never forget what we've accomplished
together
so far
and by the way the american people just
trying to stay above water don't
understand this
you tell them what the american recovery
act was they look at you like what are
you talking about
they don't understand it that's true
they don't understand it because it
doesn't make any sense they don't
understand it because if biden's
economic policies were working americans
wouldn't be struggling to stay above
water in the first place
they don't understand it because if
biden had any sense left in that dusty
old noggin he wouldn't be admitting how
bad things have gotten on his watch
but he doesn't know what he's saying
he doesn't know what he's doing he
certainly doesn't know how to fix it and
at least in theory he's got three years
left to make everything even worse i'm
so glad you like that clip now please
ring the bell subscribe maybe leave a
comment head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts subscribe to
the michael knowles show
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-n-w-l-e-s
s-h-o-w leave a five-star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]